hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be making something for
Valentine's Day I know we still have a
few days left but all this week or the
next few days I'm going to be making
some fun little festive things to get
you in the holiday season and if you
don't like Valentine's Day that's
totally fine but we're just hopping on
the bandwagon because I love holidays
even though I think Valentine's Day is a
little bit silly I still enjoy making
the tasty treats so first up we're going
to be making some candy these are going
to be little heart-shaped candy molds
and these are little poop candy molds so
depend upon if you are mad at your
significant other you can make them
these candies but if you're not mad at
them you can make them these little
heart candies and if you're just sort of
like in between and you're like I'm not
sure if I'm mad at you but things are
just extremely confusing at the moment
you can put them both together and you
can give them both I'm not really sure
what I'm saying what we are going to do
is we're going to start making these
right now these are super easy to use
we're just going to use these little
candy melts these are the chocolate
ones these are so easy you just pop them
in the microwave and it's basically
magic there's some red ones and they
come in so many different colors you can
get these on Amazon you can get them at
the craft
store I prefer Amazon because they have
every color selection ever so since
we're doing two different colors I don't
usually like to put them in the
microwave at the same time but what I
will do is put about 10 minutes on the
microwave please
hold and then I throw one of them
in and I like to alternate them about
every 30 seconds or maybe like a minute
or like maybe 2 minutes or you know just
don't even in there too long probably 10
minutes is too long so don't leave it in
there the whole
[Music]
time not ready yet I'm not ready
yet I also got these cute little bags to
put the little candies in and you can
even write like a little note on it with
a sharpie like hey you're a poop head or
hey Bae I love
you okay let's do a swap
and while those ones are cooking up
going to mix the red a little
bit yeah those are definitely not melted
at like
whatsoever hey you know it's a great
idea when you're cooking why don't you
wear a freaking sweater that has the
biggest most obnoxious sleaves ever
wonderful
[Music]
idea so out of the full 10 minutes that
I put on that clock there's like 6
minutes left so you really don't need to
put them in that long okay going to
start with the
[Music]
poops give a little shake shake
shake they'll all even out pretty
[Music]
nicely yeah some of them might
overflowed a little bit some of them
didn't really quite go into the crack
into the little tip of the Poo so we're
just going to push it up a little bit
just to make sure they're all poo
tastic oh that is a great consistency
this is perfect let's roll up these
obnoxious sleeves so this is just a
tablespoon and it looks like it's
working out quite well I'll put a link
in the description where you guys can
get these molds hopefully you can get
them in time for Valentine's Day well I
definitely underestimated how much I
would need for this so it looks like I'm
only going to be making a half batch so
that's where we're going to be leaving
off I'm really trying so hard to make
them perfect we're going to let these
cool off and in the meantime I'm going
to write some love notes on these bags
to make it super
personalized okay I'm going lay that
down for once our chocolates are cooled
off and now I need to to make a little
note on my bag to my B XO i
j you now this is this is for this is
like for a breakup one you are
mean okay I don't have anything mean to
say so I'm just going to
say I'm going to I'm going to change my
mind you're
the see you get
it so many many hours later we're back
and we've got our delicious poo candies
our delicious beautiful hearts and we're
going to pop them out of these molds and
see what we can see oh oh oh wow wow it
looks
good I am so impressed with my skill my
skill level is just
incredible look at these look how good
they are very happy with the
turnout time to pop out these
poos that's good that's funny oh boy all
right I'm here all day this is like the
best gift ever I think that if you are
to gift these you might want to be a
little more creative with the bags
because these look really not very
good yeah I think the uh the text looks
dumb don't do that you can write a
letter write a really nice letter with a
pen it's very
meaningful I think it's great I'm very
happy well thank you guys so much for
watching if you guys try to make these
let me know what you think let me know
how they turn out send me a photo on
Twitter or Instagram or SnapChat it to
me or send an email don't send an email
I don't check my email I'm to place
these out and just have them on
display for everyone to say hey hey i j
did you find a
way I don't know they look really cute
my little poops and hearts I'll see you
guys later
bye
blindfold ourselves M and here's all of
our items everything that was on sale I
was like let's put it into my basket
Justine you got some goodies so what is
in this bag okay what's going on here
we've got markers we've got stickers
we've got tape and of course we're going
to be blindfolded and with scissors we
have to be very very very very very
careful oh okay